it's a real contest two main parties
have got stuck around thirty percent
there's a six percent chance of a hung
parliament you've got a lot of parties
in this equation the turnovers declined
and the sort of two party system has
declined I think we may be moving to an
area where we do politics without
political parties coaches are more
inspired by values than they are by
tribal loyalty Britain's political
leaders fanned out in force on this the
first business day of general election
year if it all looked a bit stale
already that's because many voters seem
to be falling out of love with the old
way of doing politics it was all very
different 25 years ago when Sky News
began of course the personalities have
changed but back then people still
thought in terms of a labor or a
Conservative government and you very
much not a coalition back in nineteen
ninety this building now the TV
companies base near Parliament was newly
renovated and opened officially by
Margaret Thatcher so this was where the
victory party was meant to be heavy it
was meant to be you Neil Kinnock was one
of its first occupants making this
Labour's flashy campaign headquarters
for his 1992 general election battle
against John Major's conservatives
now many expected neil kinnock to become
prime minister in 1992 including perhaps
himself judging from his triumphal lyst
rally in sheffield talking to me a
serious or a completely innocent effort
to keep get everybody to cool down I did
what rock and roll musicians do and said
we're all right and they all shouted
back and then so I responded them and
they all shouted back and I said we'd
better get a bit of talking them here
and it all cooled down but of course
again in mythology that's developed into
an incoherent oh well the phrases
reported or has been reported I some is
we're all right which was triumphalism
which of course I didn't say back then
politics was dominated by the battle
between left and right labour versus
conservatives with the newspapers taking
a brutally partisan approach to connect
it was mental rally the faithful
galvanized the troops in the north
hindsight's a great journal it did one
of course everyone who said it was
brilliant but by that time I suspect
some of them were beginning to think
they wouldn't win and by Election Day
I'm pretty sure he'll kill it thought he
wasn't going to make it either
partager Michael Portillo was then one
of the Rising Stars on the right of the
Conservative Party the election result
in 92 was very uncertain consequently
the turnout in that election was
enormous and the Conservatives I think
rather gates expectations got a very
large slug of that enormous vote and
were returned does anybody know any
difference between the Liberals and the
Labour Party in policy John Major appear
to be in touch he did this gimmicky
thing of getting on a soapbox and going
around the country that didn't seem to
be much else that he could play on but
John Major was a man who had humble
origins these were well known and when
he got there out there amongst the
people in marketplaces in the song I
think that did have a very strong appeal
majors government soon ran into troubles
today has been an extremely difficult
and turbulent day the pound crashed out
as the European Exchange Rate Mechanism
undermining his credibility including
with many on his own side meanwhile
labour regrouped in opposition
in the door of the second of May 1997
the victorious party gathered here at
the festival hall on london's southbank
a new dawn has broken
where was the famous scene oh it's just
uh it was about here Dame Tessa Jowell
was one of the so-called Blair babe
everybody thinks that Tony waited to
arrive until dawn had broken and he
probably did but it was exquisite and
the excitement was just I think we
allowed ourselves to feel thrilled
instead of you know all this caution
that had been our hallmark firm on two
or three years since Tony became leader
but then of course that lasted for about
12 hours until we all work out the next
morning and realize that we were going
to be part of the government Tony Blair
went on to win big twice war in 2001 and
2005 but Blair was devoured in appt a
struggle with his Chancellor Gordon
Brown and other parties including the
Liberal Democrats saw fresh
opportunities but Iraq and Afghanistan
knocked a lot of the gloss off Tony
Blair and as New Labour faded so the
Conservatives came up with a charismatic
leader of their own from a new
generation David Cameron technology was
making a lot of difference the politics
as well there was tweeting there was
blogging and in Britain the first-ever
televised leaders debates there is a
difference is a real difference between
us you changed clubs of which you are a
member by getting stuck in not standing
on the sidelines of complaining about
you don't know it's coming you guys
remind me the rhyme to remind me of my
two young boys squabbling at bath time
that day here's gonna used to be in this
theater that was a three-person debate
Clegg Brown camera was that the right
balance oh I think so and and of course
what those debates did is they they
change the the language of of the
general election campaign the the three
debates punctuated the campaign in a way
that we we no sooner out of one debate
that we were looking forward to the next
the whole political agenda became about
what was said in the previous debate
what was going to be said in the next
debate and the one after that in it and
of course as you remember it transformed
the polls which swung one and truly
after the first debate and prior to our
debate well and truly in favor of a Lib
down cramps and failure here yes indeed
sky paid for this microphone and when we
have the leaders debate here in Bristol
in 2010 it seemed entirely logical that
the participants should be the leaders
of the Conservatives labor and the
Liberal Democrats but since then we've
had the formation of the coalition the
Scottish referendum the rise of you Kip
and to a certain extent the greens so
this time five years on in 2015 the
broadcaster's think we need a different
mix at the podiums elected in 2010 for
Brighton Pavilion Caroline Lucas is the
first-ever Green Party MP here we are
still battling against a political
system that seems to be set up
deliberately to exclude new entrance to
the market you know taught to be a
candidate for referral to the malapa
lism Competition Commission frankly
because it's so difficult for new
entrance to get in but having said that
I think we can see with the with the
rise of you Kip and obviously now the
increasing numbers of people voting
green there is a real frustration i
think that people feel with the current
mana left the politics they want to
break through that
there are even bigger new insurgent
forces and British politics than the
Greens the SNP may have lost the
independence referendum but they run the
Holyrood government under First Minister
Nicola Sturgeon then there's you Kip
which came first in this year's European
elections and which now has two MPs in
the Commons following famous by election
victories douglas Carswell beat the path
for you Kip resigning his seat in
clacton as a Tory MP to immediately
refight it in purple colors I think
inevitably in politics as in nature it
nature abhors a vacuum so too in
politics and 88 a party will come in and
offer people Trojan I think we're very
lucky in this country that the party
that's coming in and offering a choice
is a basically free market classical
liberal party it's a desire for a a
customer voter focused politics that
people want and I'm afraid that the the
established party state they're clueless
as to how to respond to it with many old
tribal loyalties already abandoned
nobody is predicting a landslide
election victory for either David
Cameron or Ed Miliband instead how those
vital few percent of votes fall here or
there in the margins for you Kip
nationalists or greens seems likely to
determine who will run Britain after the
7th of May adam boulton Sky News
Westminster